hello to you john morning kate how you
doing i'm good you look exactly the same
now as you did back then
uh how was the game last night
the game was fantastic i mean it was a
great night for england um
as much as you talk about the german
team and and we may say they're not the
team of the past
history has told us that the germans
always win particularly in competitions
against us so
while i thought we were we had a great
chance of winning in the back of my mind
it was always well we never beat germany
competition so
at least we've now got rid of that
hoodoo we have and
what about kane finally broke his duck
i think it's important for him because
of course raheem sterling has been our
star and scoring the three goals
but i think the longer you go in the
competition you want your captain your
talents man
your goal scorer could be in good form
because of course as much as we're
talking about football coming home they
still have two matches to play before
you can get to the final
so i'm glad that harry kane has scored
because at least going into the next
game and hopefully the semi-final
he will have more confidence because um
that's what we need we need our goal
scorer scoring goals
yeah so it takes the pressure off him um
what about sterling though i mean
seriously he's fantastic isn't he he's
totally on form at the moment
yeah interestingly his club form hasn't
been great this season i suppose that
really has inspired him to really show
what he can do for england
and sometimes club you may be a bit
complacent going into international
football because
you're doing well for your club so
you're always getting a lot of praise
week and week out so suppose he felt he
had something to prove
and he's he's proved any other doubters
that he had i never had any doubt
him playing for england because i
thought that his style suits
international football because of his
pace and his
and his skill so i'm pleased for him um
we've seen a sensational uh image that
has been published in some of the papers
today of our goalkeeper
um he was on top form as well that the
i think it was in was it in the first
half that he saved that uh goal
that was almost certainly going in
absolutely
yeah i mean you know um you you would
argue that they probably had the two
best chances with thomas miller also
missing
uh great chance to equalize and and that
got in but the good thing is we're not
we haven't conceded goals the working
thing is that we probably are giving the
opposition chances to score but we
haven't conceded
um i'm a little bit nervous about people
talking about is coming home because we
do have to
play against ukraine and when we talk
about should should we fear them
no but we have to be respectful should
france have faired switzerland
no but switzerland beat them so we have
to be very cautious
not to get too carried away and already
thinking we're in the final
yeah we are going to rome uh the england
fans cannot
go and support the team because of
quarantine restrictions what impact will
that have on them do you think
well i'm hoping for not to have an
impact because of course it's great to
have your fans there and i suppose if
you look at
the premier league season whereby people
have been playing without fans and
they've been playing well nevertheless
they have to make their own atmosphere
it's great that
they know that they will know seeing i
was actually there uh
at box park in croydon it looks like i
was that's me just trying to get away
from all the bear because i'm not a big
fan of bear being thrown over my head
but but it's important for the players
to create their own atmosphere because
of course at wembley the atmosphere was
created by the fans by the nation
in rome there's going to be no fans
there so they can't use that as an
excuse
they still have to create their own
atmosphere
um and looking forward to what might
happen in rome and then subsequently if
they do get through back to the two
games
at wembley the semi-final and the final
do you concur that england are on the
easier side of the draw or not
well they are the easier side of the
draw but france also had an easier pass
through to the quarterfinals playing
against switzerland and look what
happened to them
so as much as we are on the easier side
of the draw um and everyone's talking
about getting back to wembley for the
final
we have to take it one game at a time
because this is an opportunity that
we've had being the
in the so-called easy side of the draw
so for us
we will be kicking ourselves if we miss
this opportunity because we've got so
far
ahead of ourselves we're thinking about
the final and then we don't perform
against ukraine so all they have to have
on their minds
yes in the back you mind you may think
about the semi-final in the final but
more importantly
think about the gaming room against
ukraine see i wasn't going to bring up
france but while you have
you did say they were going to win
didn't you
i thought they were going to win and
slowly the bookies um so if england
don't when am i going to say to people
you're saying they were going to win
this is football
this is football um france were the
favorites
and belgium are now the number one so
belgium should win because they're the
number one team in the world
but football doesn't work that way does
it and that's why we love it okay and so
your prediction now is
england when
um my prediction is for england to go
through to the semi-final
and then we'll see how it goes from
there and i hope england wins
yeah step by step by step if if you go
to the bookies
yeah i'm sure the bookies will still not
have england's favorites so are the book
is normally wrong
so as much as as a fan and being english
that's what we want
but we also have to think with our our
head as well as our hearts yeah as well
and i've got a great chance of winning
because they're a very good team but i'm
sure other people feel that they have
chances as well
sure as my dad always used to say you
never see a poor bookie um
if we do get through to the the semis
will you go to wembley or are you going
to stay down in croydon and watch there
with the fans
oh no no i'm up in the merseyside i have
to be down in croydon the other day um
i won't that was just an event that i
went to i didn't watch it i won't be
watching it there the semi-final
depending on whether i'm working whether
i'm doing something for television or
maybe at the game
so i'll have to wait and see um what
options i have okay fantastic i'll be
watching it somewhere
yeah i'm sure i'm sure final thought
before i let you go john um
southgate thought for southgate he's
finally put those demons to bed
he has but of course he has also said we
have to go into this game with
caution we have to not get carried away
as much as a great moment for the
country which we have to embrace and we
have to
but he understands how difficult
football matches are particularly when
you're the favorite playing against
underdogs
so he's really trying to keep
everybody's feet particularly the
players
it's okay for the nation to get carried
away for the fans to get carried away
but the players can't and i suppose he's
tempering their expectations
by saying let us now concentrate and
treat the game against ukraine as if
we're playing against a germany
uh a portugal of france and one on one
of
one of the favorites and that's what he
has to do so he's doing the exact right
thing
okay lovely it's great to talk to you
john thanks a lot appreciate it